THERE.
>> HE WAS REFLECTING WHAT A LOT
OF EXPERTS ARE BELIEVING.
THIS VIRUS IS AN ENDEMIC VIRUS.
IT WILL CONTINUE TO CIRCULATE
IN OUR SPECIES LIKE THE
SEASONAL FLU DOES.
THIS VIRUS DOESN’T SEEM TO
MUTATE QUITE AS MUCH.
HOPEFULLY THE VACCINE WILL BE
EFFECTIVE FOR LONGER THAN A
YEAR.
IT WILL COME BACK AND WHEN IT
COMES BACK THIS WINTER WE WON’T
HAVE A VACCINE FOR IT.
WE HAVE TO DEVELOP STRATEGIES
TO MITIGATE ITS IMPACT ON US
AND THAT WILL RANGE FROM ALL
THE THINGS WE’RE LEARNING TO DO
NOW.
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND THE LIKE
BUT SMART STRATEGIES ABOUT
THERAPIES THAT MAY WORK BETTER.
PEOPLE WHEN THEY FIRST GET
DIAGNOSED AND ICU.
WE ARE SEEING DRAMATIC
ADVANCING.
WE’RE FIGHTING THE BATTLE AS WE
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WORKS.
>> Ed: THAT LEADS US TO WHAT
THE FORMER FDA HEAD WROTE IN
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL." A
VACCINE COULD BEAT THE VIRUS AS
YOU JUST NOTED BUT THERE WON’T
BE ONE THIS YEAR.
THE BEST NEAR TERM HOPE AN
EFFECTIVE THERAPEUTIC DRUG.
IT IS PLAUSIBLE AS SOON AS THIS
SUMMER.
THE PROCESS WILL HAVE TO MOVE
FASTER.
YOU HAVE BEEN PUSHING THIS AS
GOTLIEB HAS THE IDEA WE HAVE TO
GET GOING ON THIS AND THERE ARE
VARIOUS TRIALS OUT THERE.
DR. FAUCI SAID HOLD ON A SECOND.
WE DON’T HAVE ENOUGH DATA.
>> I HEAR THE WORD ANECDOTAL
DATA.
SOMEONE HAS TRIED SOMETHING.
IF YOU’RE A DETECTIVE YOU
COLLECT CLUES.
A MAJOR THING A DOCTOR DOES IS
ASK QUESTIONS AND LOOK FOR
SOLUTIONS.
AS I LOOK AROUND.
THE NUMBER ONE FEELING OF MOST
PHYSICIANS BUT ONLY A FEELING.
THE IDEAS OUT THERE, SOME MAKE
SENSE.
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IS AN
EXAMPLE.
I WANT TO POINT OUT ANECDOTAL
IS DIFFERENT FROM WHAT WE’RE
LOOKING AT.
THE STATEMENT DISEASE
SPECIALIST IN FRANCE HAS
TREATED WITH A THOUSAND
PATIENTS WITH THE OLD MALARIA
DRUG AND Z PACK.
YOU HAVE RANDOMIZED DATA FROM
CHINA WHERE THEY TOOK TWO
GROUPS.
HALF HAVE THE
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, HAVE DIDN’T.
HALF THE GOT THAT MEDICATION
HAD A REDUCTION IN TIME OF THE
FEVER AND HOW LONG THEY COUGHED
AND REDUCTION?
PNEUMONIA PROBLEMS AND CHINA
MADE IT PART OF THEIR PROTOCOL.
WE DON’T KNOW THE ANSWER.
WE DON’T KNOW IF THAT DRUG OR
OTHER SOLUTIONS WILL WORK
DEFINITIVELY FOR THE COVID-19
PROBLEM.
YOU MARCH INTO WAR WITH THE
ARMY YOU HAVE.
PHYSICIANS ARE SAYING I NEED A
COUPLE TOOLS THAT I THINK ARE
SAFE.
I SPOKE TO ONE OF THE LEADERS